the one thing i remember about getting
to the oscars is what i learned during
pan's labyrinth
which is wear comfortable shoes
[Music]
and the oscar goes to
guillermo del toro
the feeling of that night is incredibly
special
you see the stage and then you get up
and you go up the stairs and then you
turn around and you are in front of an
audience composed of the people you
admire the most in the craft that you
are part of and the wave of love the
wave of emotion that hits you that is
overwhelming
thank you i don't prepare the speech i
tried to speak from the heart it's not
about reading names it's about telling
people about your moment that is so
life-changing and
underline what is special about that
moment for you i am an immigrant
function i'll handle my compadres as an
immigrant coming from
what a harm mexico in the moment that
you receive this honor you feel you were
heard and there is no larger blessing
for any human being than to be seen or
heard
there was very little time between the
first oscar and the last in my case
maneuvering stairs
is one of the great
adventures of my life so i was kept a
little to the side
fortunately for me and the oscar goes to
the shape of water
[Applause]
the beauty of the picture oscar is that
everybody rushes into stage all your
team having never ever participated in
any sport
[Music]
i imagine that's what it feels to
participate
but
you know
it's not about you all of a sudden it's
about the group
i remember the year before with the
envelope gate and i wanted to make
a little reference to that by checking
it
in front of them
and going
this was right i want to dedicate this
to every young filmmaker the youth that
is showing us how things are done
really they are
in every country in the world thank you
very much
we have to understand that we are one
link on a chain that continues if we
have generosity of spirit
and that ends if we don't
and that it serves no one for the chain
to end with you and it benefits everyone
for that chain to continue after you
that dedication and what i've tried to
do after that night
is an extension of that that sentiment
you